[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing sirius black esteemed wizard
marauder godfather and hero sirius black
who started at hogwarts in 1971
alongside the other marauders hailed
from the black family a powerful pure
blood wizarding family that placed an
incredible amount of emphasis on the
importance of blood purity remarkably
however sirius was able to pave his own
way in life and form his own opinions
which ultimately led to him being
shunned from the family with that said
however sirius went on to become a
better man than any of his ancestors he
vowed not to let his lineage determine
the man he would become and once wisely
said we've all got both light and dark
inside us what matters is the part we
choose to act on that's who we really
are the goodness in sirius's heart
eventually led to a friendship with
james potter harry's father and well the
rest is history being friends with james
meant that he would eventually become
our boy harry's godfather which is part
of the reason that sirius ended up being
such an integral part of the story
however with that said there are
actually a lot of things pertaining to
sirius's character that were entirely
left out of the films if you've read the
books you'll know him a little better
but if you're a movie only person you've
only seen a fraction of the men that
sirius black truly is because sirius
doesn't make an appearance in that many
films being introduced late and dying
early he doesn't actually get a lot of
screen time which is why today i want to
discuss seven pieces of information
pertaining to sirius black that movie
watchers won't know let's get started 7.
he gave harry his first broom no i'm not
talking about the fire bolt that sirius
gave harry at the end of prison of
azkaban harry already had brooms before
that point i'm talking about a broom
that he gave him much earlier the broom
that sirius gave harry is mentioned in a
letter from lily potter to sirius
sometime around harry's first birthday
dear padfoot thank you thank you for
harry's birthday present it was his
favorite by far one year old and already
zooming along on a toy broomstick he
looks so pleased with himself i mean
closing a picture so you can see you
know it only rises about two feet off
the ground but he nearly killed the cat
and he smashed a horrible vase petunia
sent me for christmas no complaints
there of course james thought it was
funny says he's going to be a great
quidditch player we've had to pack away
all the ornaments and make sure we don't
take our eyes off him when he gets going
of course the broom series gave harry
here is a toy broom a broom marketed at
young children which can only lift about
two feet off the ground high enough if
you ask me
six he was friends with hermione's cat
crook shanks crook shanks was hermione
granger's pet cat a half nasal with a
very regal line-like appearance being
part nasal he was particularly
intelligent and was able to solve all
sorts of problems on his own
crook shanks doesn't make much of an
appearance in the films but book readers
will know that sirius black actually had
a good relationship with crookshanks
this is partially because sirius while
transfigured into a dog befriended
crookshanks and asked him for help
finding scabbers aka peter pettigrew
crookshanks also helped sirius out by
pressing the knot on the whomping willow
giving him safe access to the shrieking
shack five he was secret keeper before
peter pettigrew one of the reasons that
the potters died was because of their
chosen secret keeper their good friend
peter pettigrew a secret keeper is a
witch or wizard designated to hide a
secret secured by the fidelius charm
which conceals the secret inside of the
secret keeper's soul initially sirius
black was chosen by james and lily to be
secret keeper but feeling that he would
be an obvious target for voldemort
series instead recommended peter who we
know doesn't do a particularly good job
the secret in question was the location
of the potter cottage a secret that was
tied to petticrew soul unable to be
forcibly removed a dwelling protected by
the fidelis charm in conjunction the
secret keeper essentially becomes
absolutely hidden keeping the occupants
safe
four he was only 22 when he was sent to
azkaban plus his escape in 1981 after
betraying the potters pettigrew
travelled to a nearby town and murdered
12 muggles using a dark and powerful
blasting curse simultaneously destroying
hundreds of feet of sewer system and
leaving a 40-foot crater in the ground
someway somehow sirius black was blamed
and was promptly sent to azkaban however
what many fans may not know is that
ceres was just a mere 22 years old when
he was sent away which in a way
contradicts the picture painted of the
mature versions of the marauders since
we're on the topic of sirius and azkaban
let's dive into another book fact as we
know sirius eventually escapes the
island prison but many of you who've
only seen the movies that is may not
know how he did it it's all explained
here one night when the dementors opened
my door to bring food i slipped past
them as a dog it's so much harder for
them to sense animal emotions that they
were confused i was thin enough to slip
through the bars i swam as a dog back to
the mainland i journeyed north and
slipped into hogwarts grounds as a dog
i've been living in the forest ever
since essentially sirius got thin enough
by starving himself to slip through the
bars in his animagus form sounds rough
three he gave ron a pet owl at the end
of prison of azkaban ron weasley no
longer had a pet rat as it was revealed
that scabbers was in fact ex-marauder
peter pettigrew without a pet ron was a
bit glum which is what prompted cirrus
black to gift an owl to ron named pig
widgeon pigwidgeon also known as pig was
a miniature scops owl resembling a
fluffy snitch and became responsible for
handling ron's mail from 1994 onward
here's a funny passage referencing
pigwidgeon harry stared at the word pig
looked up at the tiny owl now flushing
around the light fixture on the ceiling
he had never seen anything that looked
less like a pig pig is not mentioned in
the movies at all
2. sirius did not die from avada kadavra
the book clearly indicates that serious
black's death was the result of him
falling into the veil and nothing else
falling backwards into it after being
struck by bellatrix or stranger's curse
however the film adaptation paints a bit
of a different picture and suggests that
he may have died from the killing curse
in the film in only an instant the
battle turns from what seems like a
flawless outcome for the order to one of
the worst outcomes possible the death of
sirius after finishing off lucius sirius
leaves his guard down for only an
instant and in that same instant
bellatrix lestrange appears avada
kadavra she yells shooting a jet of
green light toward him and just seconds
later cyrus black had a blank expression
on his face falling backward through the
veil this confuses things a bit because
in the book it's never mentioned that
bellatrix uses avada kedavra aka the
killing curse number one he takes a big
risk in the goblet of fire in the goblet
of fire sirius was still very much on
the run and wanted by the ministry
however now free men sort of sirius was
able to travel around as he pleased very
carefully i might add sirius doesn't
have a big role in the fourth book but
he does make his presence known a little
traveling to hogsmeade in order to
interact with harry it's at hogsmeade
that harry visit sirius was living in a
cave living primarily off of rats and
that concludes a list there are
certainly more than seven facts
available on sirius which are exclusive
to the books but i thought it ended here
if you want more book facts on sirius i
can always make another video before we
end the video i thought i should mention
that i'm going to be giving away a harry
potter box set to one lucky subscriber
follow me on instagram at hp theory and
check out the latest post there for
details that's it for today's video
until next time remember what's life
without little risk
[Music]
you